[Musique]
être vous comme ce spectateur pour lui
la boxe c'est l'art de voir les autres
recevoir des coups de plus en plus de
coups et de plus en plus le coup dur
et c'est pourquoi en france aujourd'hui
et peut-être dans le monde il y a de
plus en plus de spectateurs pour compter
les coûts mais de moins en moins deux
boxeurs pour en recevoir
votre foi du temps de marcel thil de
carpentier
la boxe était encore le noble à
l'escrimé urines aujourd'hui elle est
devenue cela
l'année de la boxe comme de la mine où
des travaux de terrassement ne trouve
plus de main d'oeuvre sur place on est
obligé de l'emporter deux des trois
derniers français champion du monde est
et nord africains
s'ils survivent des champions américains
sont noirs et danses etc triste petites
salles de banlieue ou en province où se
recrutent et naguère les champions il y
a de moins en moins de jeunes gens pour
courir après septembre tenace ingrate et
méchante la boxe professionnelle
le dernier grand champion français vient
de partir c'est charles humaine
hier on l'appelait charlie aujourd'hui
on l'appelle déjà chez lui monsieur
humaine
car à 32 ans sagement
humain est retourné à ses paysages de
son enfance où la boxe lui aussi il
avait tiré les crassiers du nord
c'est à lui que je suis allé demander de
vous livrer le secret de cette crise
vers lui mais je vous le dis tout de
suite je ne connais rien à la boxe et en
cela je suis sans doute comme beaucoup
de français comme beaucoup de
téléspectateurs qui vous regarde en ce
moment qui vous connaissent bien mais
pour qui malgré tout le personnage d'un
boxeur demeure une sorte d'énigme
vivante et c'est pour essayer de
comprendre cette énigme que nous sommes
venus chez vous et je pense que l'un des
moyens que nous avons de la comprendre
c'est que vous nous expliquer tout
d'abord les raisons de votre abandon
pourquoi quitter vous la boxe à votre
âge à l'ordre toute franchise depuis le
cutoff j'étais plus dupe au regard
d'autres formes et je vous dis une fort
dû revenir et tous les jours travaillés
terriblement toujours à me passer dans
la tête est-ce que ça va revenir ou pas
et mercredi mercredi après midi
j'ai décidé tout seul niveau on avait
souvent une amie au penser que si vous
aviez continuer plus longtemps ça
devenait dangereux pour vous
dangereux oui et non ce au box nous je
vous dise un métier qui est très pénible
et dangereux donc quand on n'a plus la
foi ils vont me suis retiré au box vous
avez pensé quelques fois au cours de
votre carrière au cours de combats
particulièrement dures ou après que la
boxe était un métier très dangereux vous
avez vous songé quelquefois aux dangers
qui guettent le boxeur ou pas ce m'est
arrivé parfois côté du port en très
bonne condition et qu'il faut des
matches durs
donc je ne les ai pas bonnes conditions
j'ai pas ce qu'il faut là si tôt
malheureusement qui arrive cette fois
aux boks oui l'ami mais tu y penses et
oui aussi ce que vous assistez au combat
de votre mari nos les débuts oui mais ça
faisait deux ans que je n'insiste le
match pour quelle raison ce que je peux
vous le demande et parce que j'étais
trop énervé puis je vous dis toujours
l'appréhension devrait le voir prendre
un mauvais coup de le voir cas où vous
l'avez vu blessé quelquefois howie plus
d'une fois en vie
alors depuis deux ans vous attendiez de
résultats des combats chez vous mais
j'attendais à la maison ou alors je
l'accompagné un peu partout mais
j'attendais j'attendais à l'hôtel où
j'attendais le résultat dehors mais
enfin je ne rentrais plus dans la salle
vous écoutiez le reportage à la radio
par exemple ah non encore moi j'aurais
préféré le voir à ce moment là que
d'écouter la radio parce qu'on envoie
les cours voix ce qui ce qui arrive qu'à
la radio le voit rien et c'est plus dur
d'écouter la radio que d'être dans la
salle vous avez été ko une fois je crois
où il cause du redoux oui qu'est ce que
c'est exactement le cas où qu'est ce
qu'on ressent comment ça se passe je
vous l'expliqué le mien vu que c'est le
seul vu les jambes coupées je me suis
retrouvé partir et puis que j'étais
course heureux je me suis relevé
trotteurs l'abitre déclaré août vous
êtes relevé trop tard pourquoi parce
qu'il n'avait plus la force ou la
volonté de nos 1 je crois que j'ai pu
être du côté 8 9 10 tandis qu'en
dites-vous on a dit de vous que vous
étiez très méchant sur un ring heureuse
que je vois de vous ce que je connais de
vous montre que vous n'êtes pas méchant
du tout dans la vie on change sur un
ring au sort est vrai que j'étais
méchant excusé mais je suis toujours eu
la leur mieux qu on appelait on appelait
et que mes matches joués et gagnés et à
box si vous n'êtes pas mais savez-vous
n'ai pas beaucoup de choses il n'arrive
jamais peut-être que la question que je
vous pose et va beaucoup surprendre il
n'arrive jamais que sur le règne tout
d'un coup ou pensiez que l'homme sur qui
vous tapez est un homme innocent
franchement qu'est la boxe thaï chi kong
qui vaut beaucoup nous ont dit on de
méchanceté vous dire pendant le match et
si je ne vais pas vous rappeler celui
qui pourrait frapper temps vous ne
pensiez pas du tout il n'y a pas de
pitié je veux dire après le matin que je
il m'est arrivé d'avoir un peu pitié
pour mes adversaires
parce que vous les aviez l'abîmé oui ça
m'est arrivé mais pendant le match je
vous dis non oui que c'était mon métier
au cours de votre carrière avez-vous été
déçu par la boxe à certains moments le
d'être déçu j'aurais voulu faire le
choix du onze jours et j'étais dans un
peu déçu
que les américains vous emmener ma chose
que c'était deux agents âgés au jeu peu
d'humour j'ai toujours entendu pas au
port par deux ans le bouffon vert des
amériques dans ces cas là quelque chose
qui n'était pas à lisant régulier je
crois week-end je vous ai promis
challengé par deux ans je crois que
c'était ma place de faire le titre oui
parce que lorsque vous avez commencé à
boxer dans votre idée c'était pour
gagner de l'argent
quand j'ai commencé nous car j'ai fait
c'est un peu comme tous les gosses de la
rue n'ont eu à coeur qui s'est formée
récemment vraiment vernet on va avoir
deux ou trois unions et j'ai fait de la
boxe je vous dis pour m'amuser comme
j'aurais pu faire du cyclisme du
football et ensuite et ensuite j'ai
toujours gagner des victoires
j'ai passé en faire mon métier et là
vous vous êtes rendu compte que pour
vous c'était un moyen de sortir de
gagner de l'argent oui oui vous rayer
rejeté jeudi mieres sommes pas mineur de
fond mineure de deux jours j'ai quand
même arriver grâce à la boxe
donc je dire merci à me faire une petite
situation avant la maison peu à peu
d'argent pour le bien de ma fille de ma
femme et de moi même oui vous pensez que
si vous avez été un jeune homme riche
vous n'auriez pas fait une carrière de
boxeur
mais beaucoup de gens risée du monde la
boxe oui c'est beaucoup de deux voiliers
jours oui comment expliquez vous cela
vous avez vous peur de la boxe il faut
s'ouvrir faut se priver pour privation 1
il faut il faut savoir souffrir mais je
crois c'est vrai qu'on a été
dans le terrain et un jeune ne savait si
on n'a pas soufflé un peu
je crois qu'on n'a pas de chance de
réussir à davos et vous pensez que c'est
difficile d'apprendre à souffrir on ne
peut pas apprendre
c'est dur c'est sous ses yeux les
ervices vous avez sauvé des taux dans la
vie pour faire un métier aussi dur que
la boxe 29-10 beaucoup de privation et
beaucoup d'ordures as beaucoup de
volonté
je crois que ce départ qu'on acquiert sa
si vous avez un fils n'avaient pas de
film est une fille je crois oui si vous
avez un fils est ce que vous
souhaiteriez qu'il soit boxeur non pour
quelles raisons pour se reposer faut
trop s'ouvrir à la boxe sources privées
fauci et pour le faire j'aurais mal au
coeur de voir office de faire de la boxe
[Musique]